and I've applied the tourniquet I'm
going to start in the center and I'm
going to work my way outward we're going
to clean the site for about 30 seconds
pull on the skin which will help
stabilize the vein I'm going to hold it
bevel up I'm going to go in give or take
about a 20 degree angle
okay I have blood return and you can see
that in the chamber right there now
remember I want to go just a hair bit
more thread this off
it's in there I want to pop the
tourniquet and I wanted to take my
finger and I want to apply firm pressure
then I'm going to hit the safety button
and it's going to remove the needle and
then I'm going to connect the access
device
so I want to connect this
I'm going to check for blood return and
we have it then I'm going to flush the
ivy I'm just going to clamp it
off and we're going to secure with our
dressing